[Musique]
personne
alors qu'est ce que c'est mais qu est-ce
qu on doute on va y avoir mirabel j'ai
regardé
qui est moi c'est une surprise qui tue
je m'appelle ulysse je suis le marchand
de sable ils amis de tous les enfants du
monde et tous les petits enfants et
petits enfants noah oui des petits
enfants noirs des petits chinois comme
des petits indiens
chaque soir je survole la terre entière
pour voir si tous les petits enfants
vont sagement se coucher et en même
temps
je sais mon sable
qu'est ce qu'il fait en simple lui il
donnera envie aux petits enfants d'aller
se coucher et vous mes deux petits amis
comment vous appelez-vous je m'appelle
kirui et moi me ramène petit louis et
mirabel quel âge avez-vous moins cinq
mois 4 est ce que vous êtes bien sage
oui il vient si vous êtes toujours bien
sage
je viendrai vous voir chaque soir mossu
n'ayez pas peur les enfants lui ces gros
ours mon fidèle compagnon
il m'accompagne dans tous mes voyages je
suis le vieux copain de tous les enfants
qui me connaissent bien
oui je suis gros mais je suis aussi très
gentil c'est moi qui embête au lit les
garnements qui ne veulent pas y aller où
il se fait tard à l'eau au dodo voilà
probants pour trouver propos au doute un
jour c'est le local et au dos
voilà à quoi nous tu viendras nous voir
tous les soirs et qui nous racontera des
histoires bon quand vous aurez été bien
sage aller boire
[Musique]
enfin bonjour au revoir au revoir
une bonne chose de faite
[Musique]
ça y est le fait
voyez petit louis et mirabel sont
maintenant couchez vous tous aussi à
aller vite au lit et si vous êtes très
sage
nous reviendrons vous voir demain soir
bonne nuit les enfants
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir les enfants ont la la la la la
j'ai les mains gelées
il fait très très froid dans le ciel ou
we will à moi moi je descend vite vite 8
me réchauffer chez des petits copains
petit louis et mirabel oh oh oh il ne
traîne pas trop nous nous rendrons sinon
je pars sans toi oui oui je suis chez
son coiffeur
asseyez-vous aigre-doux je vous quoi
j'aurais fini monsieur petit louis haut
moi monsieur vous êtes debout
vous voulez une friction oui s'il vous
plaît le noise mirabel mais je voudrais
de l'autre colonne qui sent bon
et voilà ouais c'est pire et ça fait
combien mademoiselle sur froid monsieur
et n'oubliez pas le service ont toujours
le service voilà merci monsieur je suis
va lui il a de la force votre assistante
vous messieurs les points mais affirme
un défrisage
ma foi ce qu'il y a de mieux j'ai
beaucoup de 6,7 bout
[Musique]
maintenant la remise non sur la
côte-nord pitié pas de re au milieu sur
le compte et enfin je souhaite non
seulement
[Musique]
que le bleu voilà patron
j'arrive vous êtes de vilains garnements
allez vous coucher tout seul et tout de
suite
je suis très fâché avec vous olala c'est
pas joli pas content du tout content du
tout du tout du tout on note l'ofs
l'honore
[Musique]
petit louis et mirabel ont été très
méchant il ne faut jamais se battre
même quand on joue gros ce jour c'est
bien triste
il a beaucoup de peine plus dans un bel
état gros jour 6 ou été très copains et
bien pour les punir
nous ne viendrons pas les voir demain
soir viendra pas mes 6 ans âge
nous reviendrons après demain viendra
bonne nuit des enfants rois nuit
embrassez vos parents et aller vite au
lit ouais mais surtout ne vous battez
pas bon c'est promis à bientôt bientôt
en
bonsoir mes petits amis vous savez petit
louis et mirabel sans aller au cirque ça
d'après midi ils ont vu des tas de
choses amusantes des clowns acrobates et
de grosses bêtes des singes des girafes
des tigres et même des lions que de
bruit mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans
cette maison mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
rose ours alors d envie de voir posieux
couple
mais elle met
est-ce que c'est sa passion des mots
lyon coucher moi je l'aimais lannion
s'arrête à manger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que vivent les gens auraient ils
doivent jamais se battre nice ne va pas
être content du tout ça non allons au
lit et en vitesse vilain garnement et ne
recommencez plus aboubacry affaire à moi
[Musique]
à lörrach le flore tout démoli
garnements faut tout ranger
le
[Musique]
que le travail ou d'ornement
voyez ils ont été très vilain ils se
sont battus et s'il recommence nous ne
reviendrons plus les voir bonne nuit les
petits enfants
embrassez vos parents allez vite vous
coucher et à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
quelle journée
il commence à faire froid dans le ciel
bleu mais heureusement petit louis et
mirabel ont été gentils aujourd'hui j'en
suis bien content n'est ce pas grosse
force à huy ils ont été très gentils
quel sinon je vais aller voir ce qu'ils
vont ce n'est pas naturel
on ne va pas trop longues aux jours
heureux au boulot oui les enfants dans
dix jours semaine
il est très gentil il porte un grand
manteau rouge
il a une grande barbe blanche et une
hotte sur le dos plein de jours
seulement pour les enfants sages passant
par la cheminée
on y va tout salir aura bien la nettoyer
mais elle n'est pas bouché au moins où
le nom comme m
une fois rien du tout le père noël ne
viendra pas je m'en vais aller voir sur
le toit à mais vaut deux rester là et
surtout for attention à vous ça lire non
au sol
oh que oui j'aime bien celle là
[Musique]
voilà voilà pas trop j'arrive on savait
qu'ils étaient très gentils aujourd'hui
une ulis va être bien contents mounira
ben fadhloun la ola au mieux mon dos je
suis tous un jour au plus mal son rôle
auj
[Musique]
oh oh oh et voilà mais que tu est il
arrivé gros sous revue décidément tu es
un grand malade roi veut et maintenant
petit louis et mirabel rêve au père noël
vous aussi les petits enfants embrassez
vos parents et aller vite au dodo faites
de beaux rêves
owni à demain
[Musique]
en
bonsoir mes petits amis petit louis ix
et mirabel ont beaucoup travaillé
aujourd'hui ils sont entièrement nettoyé
la cheminée pour que le père noël ne se
salissent pas ils ne se sont pas
arrêtées de toute la journée c'est très
gentil mais est ce qu'ils ont fait leur
toilette pour un héros l'uci qu'est ce
que tu en penses ressources et je veux
plus voir ça de plus près au bon coeur
mais dépêche toi ou ne fait pas attendre
nos temps faibles
quant aux trois là
jazz mirabel n'oublie pas le pitch l on
sort les ont faux combat savent
aujourd'hui tu sais on a bien travaillé
on a même nettoyer toute la cheminée on
a fait le ménage mais c'est très bien
c'est d'avoir le bénin la poussière au
produit mais c'est ça c'est très sain et
ça ça le petit louis et mirabel aussi
sont sales
regardez-moi ça qu'est ce que c'est que
ces tabliers tout dégoûtant coûts et ses
petites figures tout noir bon je croyais
que c'est joli ça pour des petits
enfants hollande et voilà encore partir
[Musique]
si je t'aurais la preuve est un e il ne
faut pas se coucher salle s'être vilain
le père noël le en près de 2 le père
noël ne voudra pas venir dans une baie
sont les enfants ne sais pas trop c'est
très bien d'avoir nettoyé la cheminée
mais d'un il faudra enlever la poussière
et bien rangé lâchant d'accord mais
c'est promis bon alors maintenant
enlevez moi tout ça et on fait vite un
gros dodo
my oui oui oui le thé ou si vous vite
j'éteins la lumière y est bon allons-y
en s'amenant soir
[Musique]
non
oh
et oui nounours a raison il faut
toujours bien se laver avant d'aller au
lit il estoit aussi gros ours
tu ferais bien de donner le bon exemple
où as tu encore été four et on est moins
orient onu des enfants à demain du bonus
[Musique]
ans
oh
on
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ont joué ce soir
nous venons vous dire au revoir car nous
partons pour notre nouveau voyage ou
groso c'est bien triste de vous quitter
moi aussi ça où il pas trop mais vous le
savez nous reviendrons le plus vite
possible vous retrouver et nous aurons
des tas de belle histoire à vous
raconter alors je veux un patron oui
descend vite nounours et en bracelet
bien fort de ma part oui
[Musique]
la jemaye encore des mouchoirs et ma
poupée préférée
bonsoir les petits voyageurs
rassemblement comment vous faites encore
vos bagages
cette fois c'est fini on a tout préparé
pour notre départ de matt et vous
dénoncez vous n'avez rien oublié
d'emporter paraguay oui oui oui qui
truste vaut ce faux pas qui c'est on
viendra bientôt
tiens ne nous prend ça tu prends ton
voyage est très gros pot de miel ne
mangent pas tous premiers jo des enfants
j'en mangerais d'une seule cuillère
chaque jour et comme cette passerelle
oui c'est promis merci le cher petit ami
7 vous viendrez dans un mois chic à la
sortie de la cote vous n'oublierez pas
d'emmener le petit poussin avec vous oh
non
un mètre avec une maman poule il aura
bien chaud il s'amusera avec d'autres
pistes jarry allons les enfants au dodo
ulysse mapei ben ainslie
ou bien grosses joues tu sais on a pris
une belle chanson pour toi et pour le
lis pas ce que nous vous aimons beaucoup
beaucoup
oui beaucoup comme ça moi c'est la fin
de la journée c'est le moment de se
coucher
la zumba
amis ils s'en vont tous sont liés nous y
allons aussi
[Musique]
2010 je n'en sais rien au jeu l'entente
qui vient il nous dira fermez vos yeux
et dormait tous les deux nous sommes
bien dans notre lit software la bonne
amie sa grosse mois
plaisir vais dormir au revoir mes deux
petits amis au revoir votre chanson est
très belle
envoyé à bientôt de nonce à bientôt les
enfants
ah bon
[Musique]
au revoir petit louis au revoir petite
mirabelle passer de belles vacances et
soyez bien gentil n'oubliez pas d'aller
vous coucher sagement chaque soir et
nous reviendrons bientôt vous voir
allons allons ne sois pas triste nous
nous car les petits enfants savent bien
qu'on reviendra vite ils ne sont pas
tristes d'un corps pas trop peu je les
aime beaucoup moins subtil tout est en
ordre pour le voyage
oui patron tout alors en route au revoir
tous nos amis et à bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]
voir les enfants
bonsoir
[Musique]
bonsoir le fera des heureux
ouvert aujourd'hui nous étions bien loin
nous avions
choix de rentrer d'un pays trois temps
avez-vous bien joué
avez-vous bien chanté avec blue je te
gentil je sors tu crois que quelques
enfants ont été plutôt méchant au bâton
mais nous étions en voyage puisque l'eau
entre un petit nous parle non codifiées
mes garçons
ce sont des gens avides petit cheverny
toi noces est trop gentil
des seuils dont nous verrons oui mais à
condition qu'ils aient une conduite
parfait
patron vous serez surpris moi je vous le
garantis alors nous nous l ont dit un
titre
bonsoir les enfants on est bien content
aujourd'hui et pour bien longtemps
on va pas
rené autre histoire
dire aux nuits st
bizarre
bonne nuit c'est petit ami
[Musique]
et maintenant je descend vite retrouvé
mes petits amis
bon le seul mais ne traîne pas trop
nounours un simple aller-retour pas trop
beau
on t'attendait dévoilait des fleurs avec
notre coeur de ce merveilleux merci le
en je suis si content d'être revenue et
nous on est content parce qu'on
attendait d'abord avez vous été ça alors
voilà des bonbons pour toi ap rhône elle
est pour toi
nicolas merci c'est gentil non moi
j'aime tellement les bonbons cela ils
sont bons ils sont au miel
c'est ma soeur emilie à qui veut les
envoyer l ordre à ariana elle et jacky
teyssèdre
oui patron j'arrive à lons les enfants
au dodo
sinon je vais me faire crude
voilà ne nous ont pas déjà tu vois comme
on est sage elle ou non cette fait pipi
au lit
eh bien demain je viendrai jouer avec
vous très longtemps c'est promis promise
et reproduit alors à kezman hammers et
sauve toi vite là je tends la lumière
[Musique]
ottoman et nicolas est bourré apprenent
elle
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bush où ils en font
un drôle de bruit ce soir nicolas et
pimprenelle on se croirait aux 24 heures
du mans au ce quoi or c'est là qu'a lieu
une grande course d'automobiles
ça me plait patron je veux je veux un
peu trop
andreu sois prudent nounours regarde la
mienne va plus vite
weaver l'amiénois elle à moteur sans
hmida ben écoute à ouaga regarde comme
elle est jolie ma voiture et elles
gagnent tout le temps que l'on vienne au
ciel qu'à une honte
elle fait le tour de la maison plus vite
que celle de pimprenelle elle fonce
regarde
à la chaussaire du dimanche soir le new
il me laisse pas d'oublier on ne l'a
jamais en côte
madame et votre code de la route 1
tu me laisses passer à traduire dans
l'impression qu'un logement de police
devraient surveiller ses roues oui
monsieur l'agent de police
je crois que ma voiture elle est en
panne alors je ne suis pas buter liste
mais un agent de police
c'est là pour rendre service aux gens
juste une heure ou deux peut couler ou
là vous pouvez rouler en garçons
[Applaudissements]
ah bon petit saut vous de votre droite
[Musique]
vous avez un permis de conduire
circulez or ce forum nous voulons vous
vous êtes fait j'ai gagné la coupe
d'asie dont moi j'arrive en même temps
vous êtes de petits as du volant
bravo messieurs le champion bravo
mademoiselle âge à vienne allons mettez
votre voiture au garage
il est l'heure pour les champions
d'aller au lit les agents de police
aussi bien sûr je le suis de service que
deux
[Musique]
oui
comme me cousin jambes police bonne nuit
cherchant à diane bonnot dit le fond la
lune
debout bonne nuit grand champion boni
grande championne corps bien
[Musique]
et vous aussi mes chers petits amis
faites comme nicolas et pimprenelle
aller vite au dodo embrasser bien fort
vos parents le fuck de bovins sévère
patron on peut y aller bonne nuit
domont
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mais qu'est ce que
tu as dont a sauté comme ça nounours et
pape lors j'ai envie de danser et de
chanter patron je me sens en pleine
forme ce soit mon échelle
[Musique]
voilà pour des charlots
je vais descendre roi nicolas pas
preneur
je vais dormir on soit j'ouvre la
fenêtre centre son bruit je crois qu'ils
ont tenu tous deux surpris si je vois
qu'il en sera
[Musique]
son tronc de tapas
bonjour bonsoir les enfants on s'amuse
on est sage
alors on danse en avant moi je vais
danger aujourd'hui avec les petites si
je vais vous montrer
regardez on ne peut pas tromper prenons
nos la main mais surtout tenons nous
bien d'abord on va tourner et par là de
ce côté mais gentiment sans bousculade
puis on va s'arrêter à tire de l'autre
côté hommes ont fait une de promenade
les chamans et j'ai à mes amis si c'est
ça vous plaît tant mes enfants je n'ai
pas baissé pas petit tour par six je
voudrais d'essai réussi maintenant
chantons tous encore en avant les bons
danseurs provost les enfants ce que
voudront suplon milite à nous fatiguer
moi c'est la fin de la journée c'est le
moment de se coucher
nous faisons comme nos amis il s'en
nourrit
nous y allons aussi sur son nuage
j'en suis certain le marchand de sable
vienne il nous dira mais vos yeux et
dormi tous les deux nous sommes bien
dans notre lit non non vous souhaiter
bonne nuit
sa grosse voix
fait plaisir quand je vais m'endormir
quand je vais m'endormir sa foi nous
fait plaisir pour le duo au tour
[Musique]
où
bonsoir les enfants embrasser bien fort
votre papa et votre maman est allée
sagement vous coucher comme pimprenelle
et nicolas aux autres on se tue son
mignon allons en route fidèle compagnon
aux nuits des enfants à demain auto bon
prono
en
[Musique]
mes petits amis
bonsoir vous avions promis une surprise
la voici c'est une belle surprise
une grande surprise future bruce iii
lourd mais bien mignonne aussi ce qu'une
surprise sur les biens nounours importe
vite notre surprise à nos deux petits
amis ce qu'ils vont être contents mon
échelle d'abord la surprise
hop hop hop on bouge et qui n'est pas
oubliée
le voilà aux brebis nov qu'est ce que
tient partenaires du calme le petit ouf
tout seul ou si tu as oublié notre
esprit plus des mois les enfants ont la
pause à plat sur la table
doucement doucement non
soldes ou lundi dans ces grands à
surprise oui qu'est-ce que ces noeuds 2
cd chocolat non situation non plus face
manche ont comme moi alors c'est du
sirop de framboise ou il ne pense qu'à
manger ses enfants allons poser moins de
questions chacun votre tour à toi pas
preneur ses rangs non c'est pas carré ou
non j'ai trouvé ces des cubes même à
nicolas ne nous vient de te dire que
c'est pas carré qu'est ce qui lie à
l'ado et le déficit surprise nous nous
[Musique]
dans ce prochain
parfois je suis pas un chien non maison
'le faut aider mais aussi wii
jean noir et bien brion et pour cela ils
boivent du lait et ils sont sages et
bien élevé ce sont mes petits neveux
jury de trancher car on va bien s'amuser
mais pas la route
au bord mais le chérubin
[Musique]
mais oui vous pouvez donner vos cadeaux
à nicolas pas preneur comme petit ange
nicolas et pimprenelle ont été bien
gratter soir le matin seulement
attention on ne vend maison
[Musique]
partons sans faire de bruit nounours
tout notre petit monde dort déjà au ton
secours
bonne nuit les enfants ont tout pour eux
[Musique]
le soir tous nos amis je veux voir
nicolas je peux voir trop beau l'autre
gros nounours est en forme ce soir
j'espère que toute notre petite famille
est sage je descends m'en rendre compte
à bientôt patrons ont le seul dont va
être coton bouge pas tant mais rémy
poussoir du petit trésor car ils sont
très bons
oui dont j'avais totaux tout autour les
sept portes toto tu vas la casse et
vient de cocher bien vite au dodo tout
au long
fo a fermé la porte à clés d'autos après
on pourra plus l'ouvrir allemands
ouvrent leurs portes ou tôt ça y est la
clé pour rappel free petite auto essaye
de tournus l'appelait tous tourner la
clé totaux coûts totaux
tu me dises avron sur la clé
soit que
alors pour ne l'incluent ne fera pas de
doute ça sert à rien et la petite peur
ne nous affolons surtout mon mail à
petit
ne nous affolons pas allant d'août on
enlève la clé de la serrure là ils toi
ne nous regarde par le trou au lieu où
je sauve au moment où j'ai une idée si
on essayait une autre clé où se tient la
clé du pack 1 très bien merci
le petit pain prône l
ne t'énerve pas tout attention là ça y
est
par leur pack d'eau l'eau le suit l'or
c'est cuit norauto bros paix
et maintenant aux deux dons allez sacré
totaux allons au liban prône l bonne
nuit là ne bonne nuit il ne veut pas ne
te fatigue pas lourd là j'étais à la
lumière
[Musique]
mais me disent amis vous avez vu ce qui
est arrivé à toto il ne pouvait plus
ouvrir la porte
il ne faut jamais s'amuser à fermer une
porte à clé c'est très dangereux au loto
moi je ne ferme jamais me porte à clé
alors faites comme l'ours la nuit les
enfants faute de pau
oh
[Musique]
mes petits amis
bonsoir il faut être très sage ce soir
car notre nounours et triste triste un
tueur pas trop inquiet parce qu'il n'a
pas de nouvelles de sa soeur emilia le
jour que l'homo paul pauvre nounours
descend vite voir tes petits amis ça te
consolera ce petit ange je veux vite pas
trop hop hop hop hop hop on ne pleure
plus mon faux fin tu vas voir tu entends
ton va la lyre tallec et c'est sûrement
une led de ta maman
bonsoir maison au sublime au tarif bien
nos ennemis toto et fanfan une grande
lettre il sauve pas la lire c'est une
lettre de quelle couleur les roues alors
ce sont de bonnes nouvelles
venez vous asseoir autour de moi
c'est une lettre t thi luu ce rebond les
gens votre maman
moi aussi je suis content je tellement
un tiers mais petit chéri vous me
manquez beaucoup cher une la culture
dans j'espère que vous êtes bien sage
avec nicolas et pimprenelle et avec
votre tonton ici tout va bien j'ai
beaucoup de travail car je profite votre
absence pour faire tel que
transformation dans votre eau dans votre
chambre
j'ai ajouté un ravissant petit berceau à
ravissant petit berceau carmet chevry
vous allez bientôt à oye qu'est ce
qu'ils voient un petit film avoir un
petit frère à un petit frère
bravo les veinards mais je veux être
encore tongon les enfants ne perdons pas
de temps
nous partons voir et me l'a fait vite
votre valise des chiffres là où vous
aident les bodins les chaussettes pour
des boutons et des états mobile au piano
ce je te mets des aiguilles et de la
laine comme ça tu pourrais très côté des
brassières merci pape rebelles tu penses
à tous
allons plus ne veut en route drapé dans
la valise tocane assez froid dans le
ciel est comme ça ils sont bien là oh
oui allons mes neveux dit au revoir à
nicolas et appâts prône l ebit au dos
deux des enfants rois et voilà je la
ferme là sonneurs médias viendra nous
voir mais bien sûr mon petit nicolas je
vais juste embrassés et livia je lui
ramène ses fils et je reviens alors il
dit lui à emilia qu'on aimerait bien
l'avoir 7,3 me allons haute ma valise
que les lourdes au revoir les petits à
la noce
[Musique]
qu'elles viennent d'avoir un petit frère
qu'est ce qu'ils vont bien s'amuser
oui mais les bébés ça pleure la nuit ni
nicolas fait on rêve d'un prenait lé
[Musique]
mais c'est une merveilleuse nouvelle
nounours sûr que je suis content au trot
est bien en route nounours mes petits
amis
excusez nous de ce départ précipité nous
allons faire une petite visite à emilia
et nous reviendront vite vous retrouvez
ce promu lé des neveux sondages lui
donnent en avant nos sources
bonne nuit les petits et grands amis à
bientôt à bien tout comme eux
[Musique]
mes petits amis
ce soir nous venons vous dire au revoir
car nous partons en voyage
oui nous portons mais vous savez que
nous reviendrons très vite vous voir
aussi je vous demande d'être très sage
et de faire comme nicolas et pimprenelle
beaucoup de promesses à nounours jeu fun
petites listes patron vous allez voir
bon le shom et aux propos beaucoup
n'oublie pas que nous partons ce soir
petit marchand de sable
nous on veut que tu reviennes vie que
vous n'allez pas trop loin que tu nous
rapporte quelque chose de beau cadeau et
beaucoup d'histoires
bonsoir de cher petit regarde sur la
table on te préparer quelque chose pour
votre voyage
tout ça avec ma conjointe coup de brosse
bon
merci les enfants merci là asseyons nous
ne partons que coucher et nous
reviendront vite vous retrouvez vert
avant de partir je voudrais que vous me
promettez
[Musique]
trop à faire pour me faire plaisir et
pour faire plaisir aux marchands de
sable d'autres amis
bien sepra mines au monde à s'être amis
que vous me promettez aussi de vous
coucher très vite
chaque soir
de vous coucher très vite
chaque soin pendant notre absence dans
ses premiers nounours oui mais vous
reviendrait jouer
sur la tête de temps pas trop sur la
tête de mon potter viol dont d'accord
alors au long du tout au tout au
maintenant on y va mise en hausse
[Musique]
avant de nous au revoir à bientôt
autre gain tout mais [ __ ] tu
maintenons le marchand de sable va vous
chanter sa chanson d'image de sable au
voyage
[Musique]
je suis le marchand de sable
la journée est finie il faut être
raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit tous les
jours sur mon nuage
[Musique]
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage dans le ciel par
dessus les doigts
[Musique]
et
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages qu'un pot
enchanté et du haut de mon nuage
je serais même on sable doré
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants du monde a des mains
bonne nuit moi je continue ma ronde au
nuit à tous les petits mots nuit à tous
les petits
[Musique]
bordeaux d'hui à tous le petit
allons en route nounours au revoir tous
nos amis
à bientôt aux bretons
[Musique]
oh
on
[Musique]